على كل حال سال الناس في العراق عن رايهم
في التنمر الذي تعرض له اللاعب السابق نور
صبري وابنته
نور صبري
ما هو الخلل المفروض
الاصوات هذه لا تمثل الذوق للشعب العراقي
ولا تمثل الواقع حضاري المفروض حريه الري
حريه الثقافه حريه الهويه من اجل بناء
مجتمع خالي من السلبيات مجتمع خالي من كل
شيء انسان حر مطلق الحريه داخل صوره بنتها
مشكله مو مشكله بس احنا طول العراقيين بنا
ان نتنمر على شيء بسيط تنمر يعني وين ما
تروح موجود تنمر يعني احنا نوصل فكره بين
هي هاي حريه شخصيه
[موسيقى]
دول العالم تحتفي بنجومها وتكبرهم بل
تضعهم في المقدمه
وتعطيهم اهميتهم احنا البطلنا الدولي نور
صبري اللي هو حاصد الجوائز العلم العراقي
الكبير اللي رفع في كل المحافل كان بسبب
او ببطوله نور صبري كافي تنمر احنا مرات
نتنمر او نحكي عن محتويات الهابطه بس يعني
ما راح كل المحتويات احنا يعني يعتبرها
ومو زينه فالمفروض احنا يعني قبل ما نحكي
ونتنمر على الناس نعرف حركاتنا وتصرفاتنا
ونعرف على منو يحكي بعدين نقوم نحكي